je pense qu'on re définir à la notion de
crime contre l'humanité
aujourd'hui c'est un crime
symboliquement atroce contre un groupe
de personnes après demain si des
comportements qui mettent en danger
l'humanité tout entière on va redéfinir
ça on aurait donc à dans chaque pays un
une sorte de conseil des générations
futures qui dirait chaque année ça ça va
dans le bon sens ces attentions c'est un
recul vous pouvez faire mieux là dessus
sur d'encouragement un ketch de punitif
ou ya quelque chose d'entraînement donc
au bout du compte
s'ajoutant aux fameuses valeurs
universelles s'ajoutant à une
mondialisation poursuivi mais encadré
autrement je pense c'est une immense
idée d'avenir